so how do we get your son to cooperate
i've been asking myself that since day
one look i don't mean to
put pressure on you but there's a lot of
pressure on me so i'm going to put it on
you
look i'm sorry can anyone else can go to
dinner with this guy
so i have a unicorn in my zoo but i
should trot out a goat is that what
you're saying
would you donate a new library to have
dinner with a goat
what restaurant
mr cooper i need you to understand
something this university relies on
donations for
everything for upkeep for salaries
for scholarships like the one your son
is currently on i'll talk to him
thank you and when you go to dinner
wear real pants come on sheldon
think of it as a free dinner i'm a kid
all my dinners are free
it's what they're asking really that bad
yes i go to this university to study
science not to help collect money like
an organ grinders monkey
you see me go the rallies and
fundraisers at the high school
i don't love it but i do it and i hope
they give you all the bananas you can
eat
sheldon donors like this are very
helpful for the university
they pay for all the science equipment
and your scholarship
i hadn't thought of it that way so i
tell them we're on for saturday
i'll think about it what's to think
about
it's a night of you showing off how
smart you are people do like that
all right i'm in
you just gotta follow president
hegemeier this guy we're going to have
dinner with sounds pretty interesting
you know he made all of his money
selling anti-static furniture for
laboratories
he's not even a scientist he's just a
furniture salesman
yeah what am i supposed to talk about
let me talk about whatever you want just
don't be insulting what if he says
something i think is ridiculous
keep it to yourself what if you just
said something i think is ridiculous
because okay maybe we need to work a
little on your conversation skills like
not calling people out for saying stupid
things
how am i supposed to practice that
what's up
try having a conversation with billy
about science
let's see uh what do you know about
quantum mechanics
my dad's a mechanic at his shop he has a
calendar with a bikini lady on it
dad instead of losing patience act
interested and ask a follow-up question
your father's a mechanic interesting
you know what else is interesting
quantum mechanics that describes the
basic particles and forces that make up
reality
let's talk about that i'm gonna marry
that bikini lady
i've been working on a theory about the
wave particle duality of light
i have a night light that looks like
spider-man but i don't turn it on
[Music]
go ahead why don't you turn it on
i'm afraid of spiders yeah it seems like
a good place to stop
now what happens you go home
thank you for your hospitality
[Music]
foreign
i